[Music]
[Music]
the legitimacy of governments
is a crucial factor not just for its own
sake but in terms of their effectiveness
[Music]
why is it that those answers are right
that you select people that they get all
this
evidence they're given time to reason
and they come up with a better answer
but that's in your opinion
[Music]
ordinary people and we're all ordinary
people that's not distinguishing one
group from the rest
are very good at coming to decisions
when they do that reasoning
collectively
we're talking about democracy and from
trump to putin from
bolsonaro to assad from the far right to
the far left
everyone claims to be in favor of
democracy but in what form
and in whose interest in the west
democracy has meant electing others to
decide for us
and now many people argue that democracy
is in trouble
were we mistaken to imagine that
democracy is necessarily
progressive and delivers for the people
can we harness
new technologies like blockchain to
enable a new
more direct form of democracy that gives
everyone a voice
or is the very idea of giving everyone a
voice an illusion that leaves us victim
to those with power and influence
democracy is supposed to give power to
the people
but how can this really be achieved on
all very big questions but luckily we've
got a great panel
to help us answer them so julian pagini
is the author of lots of best-selling
books on philosophy
including how the world thinks and is
the co-founder of the philosopher's
magazine
claire foxx is the founding director of
the academy of ideas
a former brexit mep and panelist on
bbc radio 4 show the moral maze and
matthew taylor
is a former senior advisor to tony blair
and he's currently chief executive of
the royal society for the encouragement
of arts manufacturers and commerce
otherwise known as the rsa so we're
going to start by asking each of the
three panelists to do just a three
minute pitch
to summarize their ideas on this subject
on the question
is more democracy always the answer and
i'm going to start with you matty taylor
well the first thing i want to say is
that this is an important
subject in that um the legitimacy of
governments
uh is a crucial factor not just for its
own sake but in terms of their
effectiveness
and we've seen that in this covid crisis
that it's been
those governments which uh have greater
legitimacy and greater trust
that have been able to respond more
effectively than governments that lack
that legitimacy because they've
alienated large parts of the population
or they're corrupt or incompetent or
some combination
of the all of them and if legitimacy has
been important to the way in which we
have dealt with this
crisis it'll be even more important in
relation to
the much more serious existential crisis
of the climate emergency so i'm glad
we're talking about this it's an
important
question is more democracy always the
answer
well no not more democracy but better
democracy
um and i want to make one argument in
this
initial part of the debate and that is
the representative democracy which is
the system that marianne described to
you the system where we
uh elect every few years a small number
of people
to make decisions on our behalf between
elections is simply
inadequate uh it's inadequate for a
number of different
uh reasons it's an adequate way the
parties have become hollowed out and
internally polarized
um it's inadequate because we as
citizens have become
more demanding and our expectations have
risen but it's particularly
because it's just a very blunt mandate
we probably prefer supermarkets to
parliament but imagine how popular
supermarkets would be if every five
years we voted for our favorite
supermarket
and the one that won with about 30
percent of people voting for it was then
when we were forced to go to
and what is more that supermarket could
choose what to put in our
basket and how much we had to pay for it
we would probably hate supermarkets but
that's the kind of level of choice we
have when it comes to our democratic
system
there is however thankfully a way of
enhancing representation not get rid of
it because ultimately in a large complex
society you have to have representative
democracy
as the sovereign body but you can
enhance it by the use of deliberative
democracy
which is a model much more like the
athenian original
it's a model where a representative
group of citizens
independently selected to represent a
different opinions
different demography work together
over a period of time maybe one two
three weekends
listen to expert views they have
specialist
mediators there who don't have a view on
the issue but are there to make it work
and at the end of it they generate
recommendations which they pass on to
representatives
and what we know from all around the
world is that this works
that the citizens who undertake it enjoy
it often when they
start they say i can't do this i have no
expertise at the end they've loved it
they want to do it more often
and that they generate incredibly
sensible and thoughtful conclusions
and the one example i give you and i
could give you a hundred is that in
ireland a couple of years ago when they
had the very contentious issue of
constitutional reform which involved
basically liberalizing their abortion
laws it could have totally divided the
country had it simply been
decisions made by the members of the
irish parliament instead they had a
citizens assembly over several weekends
and that citizens assembly designed the
process which ultimately led to a
referendum
um so you had their deliberative
democracy informing the representatives
who then passed legislation to create a
a referendum uh it was overwhelmingly in
favor of liberalization and that issue
rather than dividing ireland if anything
it brought ireland
together but we don't need more
democracy we need better democracy and
we have the tools to do that by
enhancing representation
with deliberation thanks claire
let's hear your pitch okay i think that
is a crisis
in western democracy because many have
turned against the idea
that citizens equal citizens can be
trusted to make decisions actually we
think
uh matthew reflected some of that i
think it was
brought ahead in the uk
in the eu referendum because it was
i thought it was interesting uh marianne
when you introduce this and the blurb
for the session when it says
democracy is electing others to decide
for us but
actually we elect others to enact and
represent
what we have decided they don't decide
for us it's a different way round
and i think parliament actually refused
to enact what
uh the masses decided in 2016 and that
brings us to a crisis
you know that popular determination to
leave the eu
took elected politicians by surprise
they'd assumed
that the agreement of the front penches
of the two main parties
the bbc itb channel 4 the big business
and the banks
would be enough to ensure the electorate
did what was expected
and when they didn't i think there's
been a backlash against the electorate
and if you think about how the
referendum result was explained it was
somehow that the
vote had been achieved by cheating or
manipulation
uh that the the idea was that the
electorate were
uh incompetent they were not able to
make the right decision because they'd
been
ill-informed people even talked about
their poor education
and i think that and and they were also
accused of being populist i mean that
became a word that's used as an
insult to uh people who support
democracy these days
and that somehow they kind of only voted
the way they did because they were
influenced by
you know some maverick big authoritarian
figure
so i think once you decide or believe
that the masses are unfit to influence
the direction of society or
lacking in capacity not trustworthy in
that way
then i think that representative
democracy does start to feel hollowed
out but it's
partly had already been hollowed out
it had become slightly uh caveated and
hemmed in
previous to that by the emergence of
unelected judiciary and courts and
transnational
institutions that had tried to minimize
the influence of the people on
opinion and we know that the sense is
that
we know best the kind of paternalism
that will protect you
will take away the difficult choices and
everything's too complicated for you
obviously undermines an electorate and
their autonomy
and i do think that threatens uh
democracy
i think in other words a technocratic
rule can threaten democracy
rather than any kind of principle it
relies on
evidence and experts to justify
action and decisions are ring fenced
away from accountability
um and i think that in some ways it
means that uh
politicians uh our politicians uh
use uh evidence and science and and
issues like that to justify
making difficult decisions taking
difficult decisions away from the
democratic arena
and in some ways the kovid crisis raises
all of these things as we all sit on the
couch and watch
everybody else decide what happens on
our behalf
okay thanks so julian is is more
democracy always the answer
yeah i mean like matthew it's not more
it's better i think there are the two
currents here which you want to avoid
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas